.
- Un cratère occupe désormais
le milieu de la cours
de l'hôpital psychiatrique
de la ville de Mykolaïv,
dans le sud de l'Ukraine.
Si les dommages matériels
sont considérables, des vies ont
très certainement été sauvées.
Le personnel a réussi à déplacer
unnqnqnquantaine de personnes
20 minutes avant l'impact.
le sens de cette attaque.
Dans l'est, la ville assiégée
de Marioseseseseseseseseseseses.
Selon des témoignages recueillis
par l'ONG Human Rights Watch,
les rues sont jonchées
de cadavres et des gens vivent
cachés sous terre sans eau, sans
nourriture, sans électricité
100 000 personnes y vivent
ukrainiennes.
Dans la capitale, les rues sont
désertes et les magasins sont
nouvelle fois à un couvre-feu,
alors que les s s s s russes
tentent toujours d'encercler
la ville.
Les frappes aériennes, elles,
sevevevevevent, comme ici,
à l'Académie nationale
des sciences de Kiev.
Encore une fois, le président
ukralalalalalalalalalalalalalale
pour qu'elle intervienne.
Cette fois-ci, c'est devant
le parlement italien.
l'importance d'imposer des
sanctions encore plus sévè
pour faire reculer la Russie.
Il s'est aussi entretenu
- À New York, c'est plutôt
la fin de tous les combats
que souhaite le secrétaire
général de l'ONU.
" " " " " "Cette guerre est ime
à gagner et le conflit devra
se transposer à la taililililil.
C'est le temps d'arrêter
de se battre et de donner
une chance à la paix.
C'est le temps d a a a a a a a ,